- Everybody let's say
hello to Tiffany Haddish.
(audience cheers)
Hello.
Oh my gosh, so first of
all, I was so bummed.
I know you got sick and
I was like oh my God
I was so excited to just hug you.
I think you are so funny and so talented.
But how are you feeling
'cause you got sick, right?
- I feel like that's God telling me,
Tiffany you went in too much.
It's time for you to take a break
- Let somebody else have a minute,
is what God said?
- Yes, I'm okay with that?
I been in my bed, I got one of them beds
that the legs raise up and it vibrates,
it's been amazing.
- Oh my God, I love it.
That kinda bed, does it do it separately
if someone else is in the bed,
do you have your own zone?
- No, no, no, this is a bed.
Well, however I decide it's
gonna be that's what it's going.
- I like that, I like that.
So you really were getting out a lot,
you even went zip lining.
So where did you do that?
- I went to San Diego at the
the San Diego Safari Park
and my zip line right there
over the animals in the zoo.
It's like a safari zoo, it's really cool.
- Oh, I love zip lining.
- I was kinda scared, I
ain't gonna lie to you
'cause I'm not used to flying
without metal around my
whole body, but it was nice.
- Do you often like
adventurous stuff like that?
I love zip lining, I think it's so fun.
- Yeah, well that was my
first time doing a zip line,
I love adventure and me and my friends,
we have this thing like
every year on our birthdays,
we gotta try something
we've never done before.
Like do something you never done before.
So that was my friend Ico's birthday
and we've never zip line.
So we did it at the zoo.
- Do you enjoy it or do you
freak out where you're doing it?
- It depends on what it is.
Like for my birthday, I
jumped off of a yacht,
I always wanted to do that and
it was very difficult for me
to do at first.
But once I did it the first time
then I was able to do it again and again.
And if you go to Columbia, right?
You can rent a yacht for like $400 a day
and you can jump off the side of it
and swim back on and jump off again.
- Okay, all these summer activities
we're giving people for free.
We're like travel agents, I like this.
So wait your ATV.
- Well, you know I got
hook up the Groupon so.
(audience cheering)
- You can't pass up a
Groupon, it's amazing.
So wait, you recently went ATV.
I love four-wheeling, so
how did your experience go?
- Not that great, okay?
So okay, so at first it was good,
earlier the first part
of the day was great,
it was going, it was in this late bed
and like Palmdale, California,
it was driving all across super fast.
It was wonderful, going up these mountains
down the mountains, it was wonderful.
Then one of my friends came
in, now no shade to Europe
but he's from London, okay?
And he would lay him
driving the peer pressure.
I didn't wanna go no more.
But I let him, I was like,
okay I'll roll with you.
And then he, you ever see that movie
"Who Frame Roger Rabbit"?
- Yes.
- And you know, when the
judge is driving after Roger
and he's like, that's
how my friend was acting.
Like he was like thirsty with
the energy of speed, I guess.
I don't know.
And we was telling them
we was back seat driving,
like, "Hey no donuts, slow down,
you gotta keep the car
straight, you're going too fast."
And then he wasn't listening
and we flipped over
- No.
- About three flips and
then one flip and back up,
my helmet flew off, I thought I was dead.
I thought but I'm not.
Just a little bruise on my shoulder
and I will no longer let a man
from Europe drive me anyway.
(audience cheering)
- It's Run Mama week,
a big shout out to all
the mamas out there.
We just saw a clip from
Tiffany's new movie
"The Unbearable Weight of Massive Talent",
which is the greatest title ever.
So your new movie with Nick Cage
who was actually just here recently
and he is like even
cooler than I expected.
Like I thought he was gonna be awesome
but he was so nice and so cool.
How was it working with him?
- He was everything I
wanted him to be in this.
Like he's a cool dude,
very easy to talk to.
He has really great
anecdotes, super cool stories
and we talked about money,
which I, you know that's
one of my favorite things
to talk about, like how to
save money, how to make money.
How do you make the money grow?
What's the mistakes you made with money,
so I don't make the same mistakes?
And he taught me a lot.
I'm not gonna share all the
things that he taught me today
because that's for me.
- That was just for me.
That's awesome though,
he is very informative
and just very like
welcoming his whole energy.
And the movie is so good
by the way, I loved it.
Everybody's gotta go see.
I was flipping out over
it whenever he was here.
But I have to say this
because you worked with
our friend Snoop recently.
I love Snoop, another
guy that is just like
the nicest human ever and so talented.
So how did that come about?
- So I've known Snoop since shoot,
since before I was with standup,
I had been around around them.
But when I did, we really
got to know each other
when I did Snoop Dog's "Bad
Girls of Comedy" for Showtime
which I think is now
is on Netflix, I think.
But it's been out for what?
Like 13, maybe 15 years ago, I did it.
And we've been friends ever since.
And ever since I'm always like,
Snoop we need to do a song.
Let me get in the music
video, let's do a song,
let's do a song.
So he was like, "yes sis like
bring something to the table."
So I brought one song to the table
and that's the theme song now
for the "They Ready" series on Netflix.
The comedy series that I did.
And now we just did another
song called "Look Like"
and I can't wait for y'all to hear that.
That's me, Snoop, Lil Wayne, it's fire.
(audience cheering)
- I love it.
But wait, so you wrote a
kid's book and I love it.
It's called "Layla the Last Black Unicorn".
So why did you wanna write this?
First of all, it's so cute,
my kids are gonna love this.
We read every night.
So thank you from a mom
for writing another book
since I've read the other
ones a billion times.
But why did you wanna do this?
- Well, I wanted to do it
because I remember growing up,
I didn't have a lot of
books that represented me
that I could like truly relate to.
Like I was super into like Dr. Seuss,
like one fish, two fish blue
fish, green fish, you know?
But there wasn't a lot that represented me
and I wanted to bring something
to the kids that they could
read and they would find like,
oh, this is so colorful, this is so cool.
But it have a really
valuable lesson in there
that it's okay to be yourself.
You know and also I'm
gonna be honest with you.
I have a lot of fans that are children
and I don't necessarily create
a lot of content for them
so this is something for the kids.
(laughing)
- I just saw like a whole
auditorium filled with kids,
watching your comedy special.
I love that you did it.
You're thinking
- They do be watching.
Kelly, these kids be
hitting me up on Instagram
and sliding my DMs.
Like I think you should have
did this joke like this,
I'm like why are you watching that?
This is not for you, it's for them.
- You're funny, it's a gravitational pool.
Let just let it happen.
So wait, you've made a commitment
to standing up for yourself lately
or probably your whole life,
but what inspired that?
'Cause it is hard like in the public eye,
like especially like it's hard
in a small town, by the way.
It's just like the same
thing in the spotlight ,
it's just bigger.
But it's just hard to do, I
feel like people always worried
about everybody else's front porch.
So like how do you deal with it?
- I try to be, okay.
So at first I used to just ignore it.
You know, people would say things like,
I see your little movie,
you have your little show on the end,
you're doing your little
and whenever you put little
in front of something,
that is what I like to
call a microaggression.
That's somebody throwing shade at you,
that can't compliment if you will.
And I'm tired of personally.
So I'm addressing it, I'm addressing it.
Like I will no longer
would I let these reporters
poop on me.
- Yeah, just diminish what
you're doing or do we, yeah.
(audience cheering)
I agree and by the way,
that's like I mean,
from a Texas girl, that's
like the same thing
as saying like bless your heart.
Like, like when you say something little,
it's the same thing, yeah,
it's like, that's not nice.
That's just, just don't
even open your mouth
is what I say, just I don't
need you to talk to me.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, that's I don't,
I'm so sorry, whatever.
- Hear the song that I got coming
with Snoop and Lil Wayne.
And I'm talking about that in the song,
that's what it's like.
- I love that, but people
love that in music,
we love like when people
break it down and it's real,
it's like real.
Nobody wants to hear some
filtered like version of life.
You wanna hear it in its raw form.
So thank you for that.